I spent seven hundred dollars on this
Beast of a Wi-Fi 7 router to get better
speed and range at my house so it wasn't
worth that crazy price tag and what is
the difference between Wi-Fi 6 6E and
seven well let's get into that and the
really weird things that I found in all
of my detailed testing this is tp-link's
Flagship router and it is insane as you
guys can see has internal antennas and
it has a ton of ports including two 10
gigabit Ethernet ports it's got four two
and a half gig connections and multiple
USBS and size wise it is a behemoth
compared to my Wi-Fi 6 router and not
too long ago I purchased an Asus Wi-Fi
6E router that I tested out and I had
some decent results but it had
reliability issues and with Wi-Fi 7
coming out right around corner I decided
to just return it and wait so what are
the differences well Wi-Fi 6 has been
out for a long time and 6E mainly added
the six gigahertz band which is supposed
to give you much faster speeds and have
less interference issues because most
other devices are on the 2.4 and 5
gigahertz frequency so if you have a ton
of neighbors you're in apartments having
that six gigahertz band is really nice
there's only one issue with that though
and that is that the range is not as
good as 5 gigahertz and then 2.4 so in
reality it's not that big of an upgrade
but I did see range improvements and
speed improvements even with my regular
Wi-Fi 6 devices but Wi-Fi 7 takes this
to a whole nother level the maximum data
rate jumps up to 46 gigabit per second
compared to 9.6 with Wi-Fi 6 and 6E e so
I was such a big jump possible well
there are multiple reasons the first one
is the 320 megahertz bandwidth which
basically doubles the bandwidth to make
it simple it's kind of like having a
two-lane freeway compared to a four-lane
freeway so you can fit more there with
that you can actually pack more data
into each vehicle that is driving on
that freeway with that you have 16 by 16
mimo so you have double the simultaneous
connections that are possible and if you
have interference instead of that block
being wasted it can actually resume
really quickly and I think the coolest
thing by far is the multi-link operation
ever since we had multiple Wi-Fi
frequencies you can only connect to one
of them at a time but with Wi-Fi 7 you
will be able to connect to multiples and
then your data will be sent through
whichever frequency is working the the
best which is going to make it a lot
more seamless but with that said Wi-Fi 7
has not yet been certified and finalized
it even though I could buy this insane
router it's not completely set so some
of these features like this one they are
not working just yet and then later on
they are going to be firmware updates
that will enable it and then of course
there are almost no Wi-fi 7 devices that
are out yet so why would I even buy one
of these well one issue that I had is my
security camera that is in my driveway
entrance which is quite far while the
video quality is terrible because the
reception and range is bad so you're not
getting the full 1080p quality and if
somebody was to go steal my package I
don't think I'd be able to even see
their license plate with that kind of a
signal now most people including myself
don't upgrade their Wi-Fi routers very
often maybe every five to seven years
years so my idea was to buy the best
latest router that I can and then once
the devices catch up I will get those
extra features but for now I will get
some better speed and better range I
spent 350 bucks on my Wi-Fi 6 router
about five or six years ago and it was a
similar situation that was when that was
just coming out and surprisingly now
it's about 200 bucks and people are
still buying it and giving it great
reviews and it worked well previously
but in this newer home that's a has a
larger property that's where I am
struggling so what results did I get
with these different routers well let's
start out with that front yard that I
mentioned my Wi-Fi 6 router would only
get 17 megabit per second down and four
up upgrading to the Wi-Fi 6E router that
left me up to 36 download and my full 15
upload which was a nice bump but but the
Wi-Fi 7 router got me to 72 megabit per
second download and then the full 15 up
so that right there achieved the goal
that I wanted to achieve but we had some
complications unfortunately now right
above my router I tested out my maximum
speed and I went from 705 up to about
1099 and 1096 I tested both of the
higher end bands for the new routers and
then the Wi-Fi 7 router gave me 1157 and
1123 out of my 1200 megabit plan so that
is excellent testing in my living room
which is about 10 or so feet away from
the router I went from 663 to about 1100
and slightly actually slower with the
Wi-Fi 7 router which gave me a little
bit of concern but I decided to keep
testing testing in my basement where my
home theater is I went from 620 up to
about 904 and 855 and then with the
Wi-Fi 7 router
11.25 and
1041. that is a huge increase in
performance and that was amazing now
you'll notice that the six gigahertz
speeds were at slightly slower than 5
gigahertz and that goes back to the six
gigahertz band having a harder time
penetrating through walls and Floors the
next spot that I tested was on the couch
in my kind of man cave area that I've
been Remodeling and here I went from 569
up to 800 and 650 with the Wi-Fi 6E
router and then with Wi-Fi 7 I got
242 and
171 which blew my mind so terrible I
didn't know what was going on I did
multiple restarts troubleshooting I
tested a different time of day later on
to verify and this was a speed that I
was getting and it did not make any
sense the next spot I tested was a
bedroom in the corner of the basement
here I went from 439 to slightly slower
with the Wi-Fi 6E router and then an
appalling 90 megabit per second on the 5
gigahertz band with the Wi-Fi 7 router
and no signal at all for the six
gigahertz band and this is why I was
really starting to worry I went to the
backyard Playhouse area that I built
which is about 115 feet away from the
router of course it has to go through
the walls and here it went from 97 down
and five up to 127 with 15 up on the
Wi-Fi 6E router and then no signal for
six gigahertz which makes sense it's too
far and with the Wi-Fi 7 router I got 82
down with only 7 Up and then no signal
for six gigahertz this was really
terrible now when I started to
troubleshoot test out why I was getting
such bad speeds the only thing that made
sense is that this huge router has
inbuilt antennas and there's no way for
me to adjust anything other than maybe
spinning the router around I can't take
one antenna point it up one down it's
all built in compared to the previous
routers that I tested so I went ahead
and I rotated the router to try to maybe
get a different layout for the 12
internal antennas and in my basement I
went from that 90 up to
224. that was a pretty good Improvement
but the issue is outside where I have my
camera and the main reason why I wanted
to upgrade to better wi-fi and that is
160 five feet away I went from 72
download which was awesome to no signal
at all and I actually had multiple times
where I would just get little
notifications from my other smart
devices that popped up they were
disconnected which defeated the whole
purpose so I had to rotate it back to
get a signal outside
and thus making my signal in the
basement a lot worse now we also have
dual 5 gigahertz bands with this wi-fi 7
router and I did test those out at the
start but my second five gigahertz band
was actually quite a bit slower even
close to the actual router itself and
then the home theater it was less than
half the speed and that's because it's
on different channels there could be
more interference and it doesn't really
make sense to me to have those unless
you're trying to not have interference
but of course what speeds that low it
kind of defeats the purpose and some
other Wi-Fi 7 routers that are out there
will instead have dual 6 gigahertz bands
so you can use it for a backhaul instead
so that also didn't fix any of my issues
because the second band was slower
everywhere that I tested so why was this
issue happening well this Beast of a
router that looks sleek and clean and
cool has inbuilt antennas that might
work for a lot of people if you're in a
smaller home but I cannot configure it
in a way that it works for all the parts
of my house and thus even though I
waited for months for this to come out I
cannot use it and I actually went back
to my Wi-Fi 6 router that I bought five
six years ago or so because even though
I don't get my full internet speed at
least I have range everywhere and I'm
just going to wait a little bit longer
to get a Wi-Fi 7 router that has
external antenna is that I could
position
for optimal speeds throughout my whole
yard and my house or I might have to
cough up an insane 1500 bucks to get a
mesh system which I wanted to avoid in
the past because I don't want those
things all over and dealing with that
one router with external antennas have
also always worked for me so that has
been my experience so do I regret
spending 700 on a Wi-Fi 7 router yes and
I am so lucky that by the time I got
everything set up and tested it was
actually the last day to get my return
label to send it back and so I did so
and I wasn't planning on doing that so I
wasn't rushing anything to test it out
when I got it in
um but I'm glad that I still could
because I can't deal with not having a
connection in certain parts of the house
and disconnect issues so make sure
you're careful based on what kind of a
home you have how far you're trying to
get a signal and and I learned my lesson
that external antennas are great because
you can't position them but with that
said the Wi-Fi 7 technology once it is
ready is absolutely mind-blowing and if
you can afford it and there's some good
options for you to choose from I would
recommend Wi-Fi 7 over 6E in over six
thank you guys for watching go ahead and
click that Circle above to subscribe
check out one of those great videos
right over there this has been Max and
I'll see you in the next one
foreign